I'm gonna review this gon that's the
title of this movie it really is that's
the title stars Amanda Seyfried now look
Amanda Seyfried is extremely attractive
it she just has these eyes or glowing he
just kind of stared at her eyes he just
be like man it's an attractive face just
that face never mind the movie starts
out with her character and she's living
with her sister and we learned that in
her past she was once abducted by
someone kidnapped and believed to have
been almost killed but she escaped now
the cops were never able to find the
place where she was they were never able
to find her captor and so she was kind
of labeled a little bit nuts because no
one really believed that she was
actually kidnapped so she goes to work
and she comes back and her sister is now
gone and she is absolutely convinced
that the same guy who kidnapped her has
not returned and kidnapped her sister
and so she goes out on this quest to try
to find her sister the cops still don't
believe her and they're after her
because they think she's dangerous to
think she's kind of a little bit crazy
and the movie takes place over the
course of this one day in which she
tries to go to all these different
places to try to figure out information
about this guy see if she can pick up
tips see if she can find out where her
sister is and hopefully find her and
save her and prove that she's not insane
I went into this movie today at around
noon and I was thinking to myself this
is going to be terrible this is gonna be
awful and I just don't care I'm just
gonna sit down at watch this movie and
I'm gonna come home and I'm gonna review
it I'm gonna have fun with whatever is
on the screen the movie it wasn't that
bad I didn't mind this movie the movie
definitely has problems and I will get
to those in a bit a lot of people are
ready to hate this movie and I can
completely understand why because I was
ready to hate it - it wasn't screened
for critics that's never a good sign
that shows that the studio doesn't have
confidence in the product and they're
not sure if they want to screen it for
critics because they're pretty sure the
critics are gonna say it's terrible
don't see it also the trailer the
trailer is really marketing this movie
as like a teenage thriller young girls
would like this movie go for a date it's
a fun stupid little teenage drama
thriller thing and I didn't really feel
like the movie was like that I feel like
the director was trying to make a
slightly more sophisticated movie I
sat down the theater I was thinking okay
let's just see what happens in the first
shot I was like huh
that's actually a very well framed shot
in the next shot I was like hmm that
shot doesn't look half bad either
hmm and you know what this movie
actually looks pretty nice I mean some
of the scenes were a little bit over lit
and I felt that there was a little bit
too much lighting in some section where
it looked a little bit too produced you
know you could tell okay this is a scene
and everything but here's the deal I
like thrillers that take place only in
one day one of my favorites is die hard
three amanda seyfried gives a
performance that is a little bit shaky
in this movie there's at times where it
worked for her and then there were
scenes where I was like where is your
head at right now what is going wait
yeah wait Kenda hmm earlier in the film
there were some scenes where she was
trying to convince the police that her
sister was really gone she's not crazy
and she was really flimsy in those
scenes but what the scenes where she was
by herself she was a lot more strong
towards the end she was more strong so
here's the deal throughout this whole
movie I was thinking there's gonna be
some stupid twist at the end that
completely invalidates everything I just
watched and it's gonna ruin the whole
movie this thing there's gonna be a lot
of dumb shaky cam there's gonna be all
these random things that aren't
necessary and there were some cliches in
the movie yes there was a scene where a
cat jumped out of the thing I was like
you know a cat okay just Hollywood
stop letting cats jump out of things
it's dumb and there was a lot of
pointless chase scenes that were poorly
filmed that didn't really need to be in
the movie just felt like they were kind
of there because the studio was like
look there needs to be a chase scene
okay just make a chase scene right here
all right just do it and the director is
like fine but here's what I liked about
this movie I was interested in the
central story and that's really the most
important part of the movie I was
diverted for 90 minutes and although
certain aspects of this film were very
stupid at like meymaneh secrets'
character just kind of alone just going
and forth into the woods at the end to
hopefully find this killer I was like
look really I mean be careful a woman
just be careful okay but I cannot deny
the fact that I enjoyed watching this
movie my attention was involved with the
story yes there were stupid things with
the movie but a lot of the cliches that
I were expecting were not there a lot of
critics will probably say it was bad
because usually critics get upset when
they're not screened for a movie
they have to go spend their own money
and usually they're just ready to hate a
movie just like I was but I'm not a
cynical person I'm not a pessimist I
always hope for something to be good yes
there were stupid and silly moments yes
some parts of the script didn't make
sense yes some of the performances were
shaky but I was interested now I'm gonna
give gon a B but I'm gonna give that
rating with a message to you I enjoyed
this movie I had fun watching it a lot
of people won't I was expecting
absolutely nothing so I was satisfied
with the fact that I was interested in
the movie and for that I will give it a
B but I will tell you that some of you
will not feel that way
that's fine this is my opinion and I
hope you enjoyed it I'd like to know do
you have a favorite like thriller like
on the run movie like that just takes
place in like one space or one set
period of time tell me some that you
like because I want to see more that I
haven't seen the next time guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes